welcome to this video playing routine
with white yeah cool teen Queens gambit
okay he's going for the classical
variation that play my usual Bishop to a
form yeah we'll see if I this is the old
main line of that night bd7 has taken
over there quite clearly but this is
still totally valid what I'm what I'm
doing is yeah a line that I am studied
yeah must be like 15 years ago and so my
knowledge is really really rusty okay
Bishop f6 this is normal this kind of
this kind of setup is intending to play
deform so that I cannot answer efore hmm
but still
yeah i can drop back the bishop which of
course allows him to take on f3 for this
end game Jim I know it looks like a bit
that I screwed up the move water I have
to really refresh my memory there it's
been a very long time since I'm I
studied this this opening line c5 is
really out of fashion and I know like
bd7 a lot better on move 6 this is what
I played is black myself so I have some
updated knowledge there from the other
side but here hmm and kind of on my own
so he's not taking this opportunity to
give me the doubled pawns Jim no okay
it's not it's not clear what I'm doing
him the move g4 is very very weakening
and really not clear if it is doing me
doing me any favor and Joe probably not
him so what else is there i can play b5
asking this night where it wants to go
probably to a 5g I don't like this
position very much maybe hear from later
rook c 2 and so on okay he's intending
maybe 94 even here hmm okay that's very
inconvenient
okay maybe I have to do this not really
liking this but sometimes you really
have to have to do something that you're
not totally satisfied with but the other
things are just I just even lesser less
attractive oh I completely blundered
Bishop tasty three queena 30 okay he
didn't didn't do that hmm ok let's let's
take them and make sure that he is not
it's not doing it after all okay very
lucky what now here I mean I wouldn't
mind to play an endgame here with the
rooks traded but I cannot easily trade
rocks him right mmm not so easy it also
has nite nite see form these kind of
ideas okay maybe go for go for the deep
on here this is slight drawback eos
black op l'exposition the pawn is really
somewhat weak the night off on a 5 and
so on maybe I can just get this pawn and
yeah that also prepares possibly Queen
to d3
yeah that's maybe not so bad unless I'm
overlooking stuff which might be the
case I I have overlooked him this Bishop
d3 earlier of course I am interesting
move now Queen d3s quite obviously not
on so what am i doing what am i doing
here 94-95 that's with this this kind of
thing hmm is rook rook see to possibly
or Lucas III kingi to as a self pen not
very it's not very comfortable him
yeah not very nice this position my idea
is to play Queen d3 or queen f3 after
all if he takes rook takes it's not not
so problematic okay it's so Queen f3m to
get this and get the Queen's traded
takes Knight takes rook a 3 root g 5 is
ok for me I mean it's even nice for me
so one minute 17 that's less nice you
can take a three but then i will take a
night f5 this is the position upon down
but i don't know rook t7 there are some
active possibilities I don't mind that
so much 96 also for getting e4 this is
quite decent actually not a not a huge
issue it's also Group D 596 I don't have
rook da double still this b6 Bishop
around Bishop b5 is a is a interesting
an interesting possibility trying to
provoke f6 which would make a route d7
far more dangerous now this is actually
an interesting move ok so I have to keep
rocks on I cannot trade rooks here I'm
not threatening to go on the 7th rank
but I can operate with rook c8
and I is taking some time now this is
not an easy position to play I'm just
trying to get the e4 pawn yeah okay I
can give the check check and take f7
this is this is more interesting the
time alone I g5 takes you for there are
no mating net so anything rook edge 895
checking f6 probably not probably not
my idea is g5g six and four checkmates
and they are playing for me that's often
a good idea in the end game oh it's not
so nice threatening mate check check
check
yeah I an idea three year for four
possible mates I but I'm of course just
promoting was check how stupid was that
black he's using all that time stupid
yeah I'm just promoting with check of
course okay yeah I was a that was
complicated holton tells me bad yeah
that could mean anything I really don't
know yeah was I was playing not up
didn't play a good game here that's
clear it started with with this year so
I came g4 I could have done that
immediately this is this is just
terrible yeah he can take d3 but it
didn't do that look at this this is just
lets a disaster yeah losing my wall I
working site down ok Knight a5 and here
I'm I think okay again 94 that's good
and now we can't say interesting it's
here this this this is an interesting
endgame I think I think this is not
clear at all a comp says black is
slightly better ok are 0.5 and maybe
maybe that's true maybe that's true but
they have some some very decent
practical chances with my active pieces
yeah this is already giving me a good
game night b3 seems to be better very
difficult night be three AR for Luke see
a droop da and okay yeah I got this this
n96 check and check your black needs to
be careful but I went here yeah maybe
bishop f
as stronger this this first that also
get snide g5 into the equation and it's
maybe better but ok and technical end
came here with 40 seconds it's not so
easy Oh came here intending g6 I was
wanted to threaten mate gently I could
have done that and now I am check this
chick didn't see that at all seems to
end in a draw though yeah he will he
will promote him
check yeah that's a draw well yeah it's
very complicated stuff this is probably
a really good for black check but not
not entirely easy or anything yeah yeah
I'm here we're talking about the draw
check ok this is this is the arrow he
has to go back and then it's a draw with
this now you have this move I can take
if form that's important yeah okay thats
it's just super difficulty with this
time I know it makes them really
promoting he has no way out of that
rugae one I can take so it took me
awfully long to realize that it's a
check on g8 okay well it was a tough
game thanks for watching